University is very well known for his
contributions and parallel algorithm
design and programming languages
um so he received his PhD from
MIT in 1988.
it's also recipient of many awards
to follow the IEEE Charles Babbage award
as well as the ACM Spa parallel
Computing award so today God is going to
be telling us about parallelism in
dynamic
I think
feel free to ask questions at any time
um so Helen introduced some of the ideas
which is helpful for me so thank you
um so I'm going to be talking about
dynamic graphs and in particular how to
use parallelism and concurrency so it
follows up on what Helen was talking
about
um so as you know everyone in the room
knows about Dynamic algorithms
inherently they're tend to be very
sequential you're doing one thing you're
doing one insertion One update at the
time that's the whole idea
uh and so what opportunities are there
for parallelism
to get uh you know get for performance
there's actually two reasons uh
so basically uh
you know
anyway so we're gonna I'm gonna be
talking about two types of uh uh you
know ways of paralyzing Dynamic
algorithms the first they're batch
parallel Dynamic algorithms uh Helen
introduced this idea I'll go into more
detail
uh and wrap in the seconds rapid streams
of updates and queries and uh hell I'll
introduce that a bit too uh I'll go into
more detail
there's actually two advantages to doing
batches of operations
um together so instead of doing one
update doing 100 updates so a thousand
updates
uh the first is of course parallelism at
least you can get some parallelism from
doing the updates uh the second is
actually you can actually reduce the
work uh per update so we'll see several
examples that if you do batches of
updates uh or even batches of queries
you can reduce the work over what you
would have done is if you did them one
at a time
um so I'll talk about that and then
we'll go into the uh streams
um
so
the goals here are
you know basically we've grown to do
these batches of updates to get
parallelism and of course there's you
know a lot of real world goals here we
might be uh you know Google or Facebook
and we want to make uh
we've got a maintaining a web graph
which might have uh you know many
billions even a trillion edges
and we've got it's very Dynamic right so
we've got people adding friends removing
friends uh at a very rapid rate
um and you know so we'd like to be able
to get some you know this could be you
know Millions per second or even you
know
certainly thousands per seconds of
updates and we do it this fast so that's
sort of the motivation for doing uh
paralyzing the the dynamic updates
um there's many different kinds of
batches that you might think about doing
in in parallel many different ways that
you could have types of batches okay uh
from sort of the dynamic algorithms work
we know that there's sort of incremental
algorithms where we're just doing
insertions uh there's fully Dynamic
algorithms where we might be doing
insertions and deletions the sliding
window context where you might be uh
doing arbitrary insertions but you're
only deleting the oldest uh so you've
got some window and you're sliding
things off the end
uh we might have mixes of uh basically
updates and queries which sequentially
this is just trivial because you just
have a few updates and then a few
queries but in parallel you might say
well what if I have you know a mix a
sequence of updates and queries you know
maybe I have seven updates a few queries
and I want to execute all my updates and
queries in parallel okay and It's tricky
because each of the queries has to only
see the updates before it
so we can't just shift the updates first
and then the queries later right because
the goal might be that I want to every
we have any queries interleaved with
updates and we want to have each query
only see the updates uh before it and so
this might seem impossible to do in
parallel uh but we'll talk about how it
actually is possible and not only that
but
uh
specific algorithms to do it uh there's
also the case where the data might be
kinetic you might actually have moving
data and you want to process these uh
you know we want to keep track of events
you might want to for example maintain a
convex Hull as points move
um so uh we're going to be talking about
algorithm in a specific
uh model for parallelism uh I'm going to
be giving some bounds for different
algorithms and so when I talk about
bounds I'm going to be talking about two
types of bounds one is work is a total
number of operations
and the second is sort of the depth of
the computation so you can think of
parallel computation you might think of
it like a circuit and so we care about
the total number of operations and the
uh the depth of the computation so this
is a standard Model A lot of work and
parallel algorithms done in this model
nowadays there's variants with these
models for example when you're doing
parallels and you might have imagine
just having binary forking
versus multi-wave forking there's also
what kind of memory operations you have
it turns out that these differences
really only make a difference in the
logarithmic difference in the span and
almost never make any difference in the
work okay so the model is reasonably
robust against across these different
variants of the model as long as you're
not over optimizing for the uh the depth
of the span of
it doesn't so I guess the bottom line is
you know don't worry about logarithmic
factors in the depth and we focus more
and we've uh I've done a bunch with my
colleagues who've done a bunch of
different work uh several of these
colleagues and the audience
over over the last handful of years I
just list here and I'm gonna go just on
the subset uh so we did some we've done
some work on uh oil or trees some of you
might know about oil tour trees showed
so what's interesting here is you might
know all your tour trees basically allow
links and cuts in logarithmic time per
operation uh so here's a case where not
only are we reducing the uh getting
parallelism but we're also reducing the
cost per link a cut right because in it
login over K can be less than log n if K
is large for example let's say k was
quick K is a number of updates number of
links are cuts and as I say the data
structure so if this was for example
square root of well let's say it was
something close to N let's say n over
log n then this would be less than
um
uh
as you go on it discuss
am I to think of the inputs again as
sequences uh so that the uh if uh if
they're I guess yes yes so the question
is should we think of the you mean the
the updates the sequences yeah
so in this case uh let's think let's
imagine that they're independent so I'm
given a graph uh I'm giving a uh let's
say it's a batch insertion I'm giving uh
you know some subset of the the edges
which I know are in there okay and I say
sorry the deletion will be about batch
that's in there for the insertion B
batch it's not in there and I'd add them
all at one
so it's not a sequence in in your sense
yeah
um thanks
uh also there's batch parallel Dynamic
graph connectivity uh so this is for
example it's basically it's based on the
uh homes which
Europe
uh algorithm so it's a parallelization
so it allows for their algorithm does
basically uh log squared in uh time per
operation if I remember correctly
uh so
um for per update uh so this again you
can reduce the cost per update if you
batch them so this is basically
maintaining graph connectivity with
batch updates
um and it's polylog span so it's uh
basically you can do a batch of K
operations in parallel
um then there's also parallel this this
is for
um
more Journal batch Dynamic trees so as
many of you might know oil Attila trees
only sort of allow a subset of all the
types of operations you might want on a
on a tree uh this just generalizes it to
more General trees
what I'm going to be talking about today
are actually these two results one is
for batch incremental minimum spanning
trees okay so we want to basically add
batches of edges to a men's spanning
tree
um
in parallel and uh and it then that in
turn has applications to various other
uh algorithms you might want to
implement it particularly allows you to
do the general sort of sliding window
which actually allows you to delete uh
edges in a structured way
and then we'll talk about Parliament
cuts which might not seem like a dynamic
algorithms problem but uh inside of Min
Cuts there we make heavy use of dynamic
algorithms and this is actually where we
use the sequence of uh it turns out you
need sequences of updates and queries in
most of the Min cut algorithms
okay so I'm going to start with uh
one of the earliest Dynamic graph
algorithms
I don't know if it was the earliest I
probably there were other ones before it
but it was Slater and tarjan's Link cut
trees okay in the original paper they
had this is ideas you maintain a tree uh
and here it's a weighted tree
and we're allowed to cut edges and Link
edges as long as we maintain it as a
tree and then we're allowed to do
various sorts of queries on it okay so I
believe in the in the original link cut
trees they mostly did path queries so
they basically ask uh you know what's
the minimum on a path what's the maximum
on a path I guess you could also do sums
of paths Etc
uh you know at any given time so the
updates of remove and delete edges the
queries uh give me some property of a
path
so uh these well showing how to do these
in logarithmic uh time back in the early
80s
um and then they use this it is very
simple once you have link cut trees they
they had two example uses of this in the
paper one was for Max flow the other one
was for uh you know incremental mint
spanning trees and it's a very simple
idea is once you can make these queries
path queries it's very easy to do an
incremental men's spanning tree because
what I do is I just add my Edge
okay so I'm doing incrementing by adding
a new Edge it's got a certain weight and
of course what I want to do now is
remove look at the cycle that that
creates okay and remove the max of the
cycle so that just means do a path query
between these Max Max aquarium between
those two
versus
so some of you have at least taught
these and this in classes before so of
course now we want to do a batch right
so this this uh lectures about batches
um
and
okay so we want to do a batch now so
instead of having one Edge we're going
to have let's say we want to add these
three edges
and now you might say
uh well what I'm going to do is I'm
going to try to remove in parallel I'm
going to do the same well all of them
right all three of them I'm going to
find the Max on the cycle
and remove those okay I think you'll
convince yourself that that's
probably not going to work
the problem is
the problem is basically two of them are
going to find the same same Edge right
and in this case I guess
you know if this cycle and the other one
next
so you're going to basically end up
removing the same Edge and you're not
going to get a correct graph
um so the issue is so how do we actually
add these uh as a batch
so what you can basically do is you
let's okay I don't like this click here
is it going to start here and what you
want to do is you want to add these
edges
okay and so what I'm going to do is I'm
basically going to realize that a bunch
of this graph is not very helpful in the
sense that it's all this stuff hanging
off the edge is not going to be very
helpful right furthermore even after I
take these things off the edge I've got
these two edges here and it's probably
clear to you that all I care about is
the max of these two edges
the bottleneck so what I can do is once
I've identified those uh sort of these
the the endpoints of all the edges I
want to add
I can sort of prune this graph right is
I can get rid of the uh
these degree one vertices okay or
anything that hangs off of the paths
okay and then I can also compress
uh paths which don't have any of the red
vertices on them
so now let's say I've compressed this
graph to to what's left here
uh you can probably convince yourself
there's only going to be basically a
most a linear number in fact there's
going to be few of these black nodes
than the other red nodes
so at this point I can add
uh the green edges these are the ones
I'm considering adding some of them I
might keep some I might not right
um so at this point how can someone
suggest a way for me to update them in
spanning tree
create a new right on this graph I can
compute a new Min spanning tree okay
which would be that one which basically
says I want to keep the eight and the
five but I'm not going to keep the six
right
and so I compute this new spanning tree
and spanning tree and uh that tells me
which ones I want to keep it also tells
me which ones I want to delete right
because it tells me basically that I'm
going to delete the 6 and the 10.
out of here
and so that's the basically the the
algorithm the ID of the algorithm so we
can add a batch
now doing that sequentially you could
probably come up with the own ways of
doing this sequentially reasonably
efficiently
um of course we have to do this in
parallel okay so the interesting part
here there's actually two interesting
parts we need to do in parallel one is
we actually have to do that remember we
did that compression part of the way we
have to basically prune off all the
unimportant parts of the uh tree the
other part is we have to update the uh
tree itself right so we have to add the
edge Phi eight and five when we have to
remove the edge ten and six okay I'm not
going to ex well I'll briefly explain
how to do the uh the updates okay that's
the updating we basically going to keep
a dynamic tree of some kind like a link
country and we're allowed to do batch
links and cuts so we can do a batch link
we're going to add those two and then a
batch cut
okay
um removing those two but we also want
to be able to do this contraction so
let's go into how to do that
okay and the idea is actually comes from
something called a rate compressed tree
which dates back to the uh
mid 80s was actually work on Parallel
algorithms and it was a technique for
taking a tree of urban literary shape
and Contracting it down into a single
node uh in a lot of the logarithmic
number of rounds and this can be applied
to for example evaluating expression
trees a lot of operations on trees can
be done or even finding uh you know
maximum weights on paths Etc
and it's a very simple algorithm is you
basically repeat
uh two steps and these are done in
parallels what you first do in one step
is you find all the degree one vertices
and you rate them off
okay
so you just pull them off so we identify
the degree one
and that's what we're left with and then
we alternate that with another round
which finds a independent set of degree
two vertices
okay and we compress those out okay so
here we've ident there's actually
various choices we could have picked we
could have picked cni but what's
important here is that the uh the H and
D are independent right so now we
compress those out we identify them and
we compress them out
okay uh it's not hard to convince
yourself that after logarithmic rounds
of rakes and compressors you're left
with a single vertex
you could to fix pick the independent
set here you could do it by random uh
so-called random mate is everyone flips
a head and tail and if you're ahead and
your neighbors are uh Tails then you you
pick yourself and you pick a con
basically a constant fraction of the in
expectation of the nodes would be picked
uh so as long as you pick a constant you
know some it doesn't even have to be a
maximal independent set it just has to
be within a constant factor of a maximal
independent set which is pretty easy
any questions about this
so anyway this
leads so first of all it gives an easy
way to paralyze uh Contracting this tree
but if you actually keep track of what
what's done during the contraction it
actually what it's basically doing is
building a balanced Tree on top of an
unbalanced tree
is what you're doing is uh so these are
basically representing sort of a
clustering so we first basically do in
one step we do all these things so these
are the rakes and you know compress
right and then at the next level we do
another set of rakes and compress and it
basically builds you a hierarchy
okay it fills you sort of a flat uh you
know a balanced Tree on top of a uh
unbalanced tree
okay
and for those of you who are familiar
with things like top trees this is
similar to top trees although it you
know it wasn't this wasn't uh originally
designed for dynamic trees although uh
it actually has some advantages with
Dynamic trees in the sense that it's
easily it's well known how to paralyze
this okay
laughs
so Miguel of course knows top trees
um and so
um anyway you get this balance Tree on
top of an unbalanced tree and so let's
look at how this might help us do the um
well I should mention that
to do updates remember we want to do
links and cuts on this batch links and
cuts so we want to remove a bunch of
edges it turns out and I'm not going to
describe how this works but you can do
these on this tree basically you can do
a bad batch of links or batch of cups
Cups by basically updating this tree
okay I'm going to look at the this
compression which is this idea we want
to sort of if I give you some set of
endpoints here I want to get rid of
everything that's unimportant right so
in this case I'm certainly going to get
rid of these pieces of the graph okay
and I want to do that work efficiently
in the sense I want to do that in
somehow that work that's close to the
number of points I'm adding so in
particular it's going to be within a
logarithmic Factor
okay so well how do we do that well if I
haven't this tree my endpoints JK and
and uh C what I'm going to do is I'm
going to basically go up the tree to the
root okay and I'm going to mark all from
from those three nodes everything on the
way to the root okay
uh there's actually going to be K Times
log n over K Max of those
so that's how many nodes I'm gonna have
to visit
so now what I do is everything that's
not on that path I just throw away
so in particular I only have to look at
children of nodes I visited so this is
this I'm throwing these away is
proportional to the number of orange
nodes there okay and that's those
everything that disappeared here right
there was something here and here and
here which disappeared
okay and there's one other step is I
also would like to do some contraction
along here well it turns out to remove
the B and the C all you have to do is
look at the nodes which only have one
yellow child with a b and the C okay and
you can throw away uh uh the the vertex
that's associated with that
so in this case I can throw away the
I guess it's a b yeah I'm going to throw
away the B and then I can do the same I
guess this node here only has one Active
Child and so I can throw away the e
and I'm left with exactly what I want
so this does work that's a proportion to
the number of yellow nodes here which is
at most
K which K is the three here is the
number of vertices I'm compressing that
I want to keep
Times log n over k
because that's as many the most
ancestors you can have assuming this is
some sort of balance tree here
so that gives you a way to basically
compress this tree in uh you know work
efficiently and K log n over K total
depth of sort of login you just
said can you remind again where did the
N over K again come from this here
uh this is if you in a tree what happens
assuming that it's
it's it not only has to be log n height
but that it has to basically be
shrinking at a constant Factor at each
level then just this is a general
property of balanced trees is a number
if you give me any uh K Leafs of a
balanced tree the number of ancestors is
the most basically K login over K
because what happens is they meet as
they come up the tree and then you're
going to be double Counting
if you're not knowing this like is
spending tree verification known to be
linear time and log depth or is that
oh expanding treatment
oh verification well you can do Min
spanning tree and randomize linear work
yeah so that's well so the same bounds
as whole for sequential also held in
parallel right I guess I was thinking
by the way the algorithms I'm describing
here are randomized I should point that
out I see
uh log n over k
um okay for the reason you just said
yeah
wait what what
you want to get if you're willing to do
randomize algorithms there are linear
works so it's not crazy well I don't
know I guess I guess at some point the
dynamic lower bounds area so I don't I
don't know what you should hope for yeah
I'm asking what you should hope for Okay
so
I remember K here is not we're talking K
is not it's a number of updates not the
number the size of the graph right now
whether this is optimal or I don't know
that's that's a good question if that's
what you're asking whether you can get
rid of whether you can get rid of the
log whether you can get rid of the log
you know honestly I think it's going to
be difficult but yeah you know I'd love
to talk to you about it
um you might get some hard sell for more
bones
[Music]
connectivity
thank you okay
well maybe because this is being
recorded maybe if you want to have a
conversation like take a mic because
other people would want to hear it I
might want to think twice
I'll just I'll repeat what uh what what
he said as far as I understood is that
there might be some cell complexity
lower bounds and make this impossible
[Music]
you know you this is sort of like
point-to-based type algorithm say you're
not going to do better than
a little bit okay
so they might be lower bounds so I
haven't looked at the low balance but
yet
um so anyway this gives just to
summarize the whole algorithm uh so if
you want to update a batch of uh edges
which now it's an incremental algorithm
so an update basically means just add a
bat of edges
what we do is we uh We've basically
we've uh have this Dynamic tree we
maintain this uh C tree
so at the beginning of the step we have
an RC tree for a tree okay we as I just
showed we do this uh pruning to shrink
it down to size uh k
okay and that took K uh you know these
bounds here K log and over k
um then we compute the MST on the
compressed graph okay and this can be
done randomized in uh in K time although
I guess we've got
more time here this is I guess what the
question was is could we actually
there's two parts of the car so this one
can be done in K time uh this one is you
know as far as I know this is
um
and then uh now we've got now we know
which edges are new edges and which
edges we have to remove so anything that
was in the tree that's not in the men's
spanning tree we have to toss anything
that's been added that we keep of the
new among the new edges we insert so
that's just a batch uh insertion and
batch lesion to the tree I didn't show
you how to do that but you'll have to
believe that
questions about that
okay so that's the uh basically idea of
how to do a batch so it's an example of
how you would do a batch incremental
algorithm
okay in parallel
uh then this in turn has applications to
uh the sliding window uh context and
this is some of you might have seen this
idea of a sliding window is what you
have is you maintain sort of uh two
fingers and so you're basically
maintaining some set of the current
edges okay and then you can insert new
edges and so let's and now we can do a
batch insertion of new edges so I'm
going to suddenly insert some set of new
edges
okay and then I can also expire new
edges so I can shift it over now this is
not a a fully Dynamic algorithms because
I can't expire any Edge I can only
expire edges off the end of time
so uh with you know with our incremental
MST it actually turns out to be uh not
very hard to implement uh the sliding
window algorithm not for msts but for
simpler problems in particular for
connectivity case certificates by
Partners psychofriness
Etc
and the basic idea is if you just think
about it for connectivity is you and
basically encode the weights as time
right and so a shift over time basically
just means uh you're going to ignore any
edges which have uh
you know weight below some certain Edge
so you just delete those edges and then
Spanish people
and you can do similar sorts of tricks
with these other prop problems so it's
very easy to do a siding window now I
mentioned that it's also possible to do
connectivity in the fully Dynamic
setting
if you remember that was sort of log
squared in this is only log sort of log
n you know modulo the Innova K uh
furthermore it's very much simpler than
the uh
not to complain about your your
algorithm but it's it's not the simplest
algorithm in the world right
before when you leave this like
what kind of specification are you
talking about here I'll be honest I
can't remember if this is a couple years
ago yeah
but uh yeah
okay questions
okay now I wanted to talk about the the
batch this is somehow more perplexing
that that's this is even possible is the
idea of uh mixed batches of updates and
queries
okay
so
let's say I have a
you know these are the sorts of
query I've got two types of queries and
two types of updates okay it turns out
the these are the sorts of queries and
updates which are needed in many of the
Min cut most efficient Min cutouts
the analog squared and
typing and cut algorithms
um so
basically right we might want to uh
basically do a query where we're asking
for the uh the minimum on a path or the
minimum you know a sum of a path or the
minimum or sum of a sub tree
so we can identify a sub Tree by just
identifying the root of the sub tree and
maybe the direction it points and we
just want to like some of that subtree
or the Min mid Edge weight on that
subtree and likewise will pass we could
just Identify two vertices
and the updates are similar they you
know we can update the weight on a path
so I can give you two endpoints and I
say add seven to everything on that path
right so I can take a sub tree and say
add seven to everything on that subject
so these are let's say we want to
support a a dynamic data structure that
supports these uh in the sequential
world it's well known how to do this
using top trees RC trees uh link
countries original ones weren't designed
for subtrees but you can actually even
modify those so they work for some
operations
but now what we want is we have a
sequence of these and a mix of these
updates and and uh queries and we want
every query to answer relative to just
what was in front of it
but we want to do that batch in parallel
okay so that's that's the goal turns out
that this is a important in many like I
say uh
Min cut algorithms these sorts of
operations and they do get applied
sequentially you do you basically go
through you know edges and you add add
so some weight between the two endpoints
and then you do some query and then you
do a few more updates a few more queries
and then just interleaved in that
right so
this is like my offline problem it's
offline so I know I know the sequence
ahead of time so that's a good thanks
for answering so I know the sequence of
queries and updates okay I can calculate
that ahead of time okay but I have to
answer each query relatively only uh
what's happened before and not what's
happened after
there's a contact is clear
um
so it turns out that as long as you have
your your operation satisfy uh so what
we show is a some restrictions so it
turns out it's not fully General okay
uh as long as your operation satisfies
this simple operation restriction
okay
which basically says uh it's based on
the notion of an RC tree although I
guess we could I'm surely generalize
this to top trees as well is what you do
is you as long as you store
um
value basically we can answer queries
okay and make updates under these
following rules that basically each node
of that tree you know I showed you that
RC tree that balanced tree that we put
on top of the unbalanced tree
as long as you can basically store uh
some values you know on each node and
for updates what you do is you can
always just update the value of a leaf
and propagate it up to the root okay and
then update the values you know so you
think of each maybe the node is the sum
of everything below it right
uh and as long as the queries
basically only have to Traverse from the
leaf up to the root okay so every node
in our original tree uh you know a
corresponds to a node in that uh that
balance tree that we built on
it turns out that uh most
of the standard queries and you know
like subtree queries and path queries
you can implement it this way
okay and then we show that basically uh
if you give me an arbitrary sequence of
updates and queries of this flavor I can
answer them in parallel in uh sort of
work efficiently so these would be login
operations by the way here I've lost the
over K here so I can no longer do this
in the over K so now it's actually K log
n
work so that's the you know if I ran it
sequentially that would be the
sequential time and this matches so it's
work efficient this is how long it would
take sequential right uh and uh a
polylog span so I can do this in
parallel
order K you know extra memory beyond the
memory for the trees Etc
question about the balance what's
happening
I'm not going to uh
go into details how this works but
basically the idea I'm just going to
give it sort of a high level idea is
what you do is you put your operations
at the leaves and they each have a time
stamp in the sequence you know one two
three four five six seven eight okay and
then you go up from the leaves do I have
a picture of this
you go up from the leaves and you
basically merge the time stamps as you
go up so each internal node will have a
sequence that's uh as long as it's as
its uh number of you know it's subtree
size okay sorted by timestamp
and then what you can do is sort of like
a so-called prefix sums where everyone
can calculate everything that happened
before it so you know from the point of
view of the updates you know uh what
happened before use and then the queries
basically know which of those locations
to look at the time so you know a query
at time 27 will go look at the updates
at time 26 and everything that happened
before it and that's the result of the
prefix sum
and so uh you basically propagate this
up it's going to be K login work because
the total number of these lists get
bigger as you as you go up so the root
is going to end up with a list of size K
right a sequence of size K and in fact
the total weight of each level is K
right there's a bunch of it's Singletons
at the bottom and then you know pairs at
the next level Etc and so the total uh
work is uh K log n
okay so basically you propagate up this
information okay you could do that just
for the updates you could propagate it
up and down and then you can have the
queries then go and figure out which the
the correct uh in reality is what you do
you do all the updates and queries
together all the queries look at uh
basically the prefix sum of everything
before it
uh and calculates the output
any questions about that
okay so it turns out that you can use
this as a sub step
in a bunch of different uh algorithms uh
in particular we used it in into uh
reduce Min Cuts so there was a recent
result which basically uh reduced uh
uh you know pre until about three years
ago the best that was known was M log
Cube then for Min cuts it was improved
to logs M log squared n and the
sequential context and we showed that
basically using this approach we can get
M log squared in in the parallel context
with only
a polylog depth
we actually used this idea in two
different places and I don't want to go
into details of uh Min cut algorithms
one is in paralyzing the so-called true
respecting Cuts okay
and getting that down to M log n time
and it turns out you need to log n of
these steps so it's going to be n log
squared end time
and the other is actually in a uh cargo
it turns out a sub step of cargo's
original You Know M law Cube then
algorithm is an approximate uh
minspan a minimum cut algorithm which is
some of you might have taught in in your
algorithms courses is whether you pick
uh basically the the Min randomly pick
weights and then it can track the tree
until it's a Singleton
um and it turns out that you can use the
same idea of batch updates and queries
uh to implement Implement that
efficiently
um
any questions
okay so that what I've been talking
about so far is basically uh
uh you know batch uh
Dynamic algorithms right we went through
a batch incremental Min spanning tree as
I mentioned there's several other ones
um and then we there's two reasons that
you want to do batch uh Dynamic
algorithms one is you actually got a
situation where you're getting batches
of updates uh and the other is as a sub
step in another algorithm okay
in fact I was very interested when I
found out that you know a lot of the new
ideas in Max flow
uh have uh Dynamic algorithms in them
and I was wondering if I could apply the
batch
Dynamic algorithms to them but
apparently there's other parts of the
algorithms which make them very
sequential so it seems unlikely that we
can apply these at least for now ideas
to you know so which make heavy use of
of dynamic trees and sequences of
updates and queries
okay so 9x part is basically uh
related but different works so here the
context is we have in fact this is
someone asked well what's the difference
between batch updates and batch Dynamic
algorithms and concurrent algorithms
okay so this is almost the first part
was in batch Dynamic algorithms we have
a graph with getting batches of updates
and batches of queries
and in this one we it's much more of an
asynchronous setting so this is sort of
a what's often called the concurrent
setting so we don't have synchronous
batches okay we have a situation where
we might have this very rapid Upstate
stream
so these are individual updates that
this is just add a single edge add a you
know delete a single edge Etc
okay
and then what we're trying to do is we
might want to then look at this graph
and do various analysis on it so it it's
not really a dynamic algorithm instead
of I'm not actually maintaining a MST
but what I want to do is I want to look
at this graph and I want to calculate
the MST I'm going to calculate the some
clustering I want to do some you know
query this graph some of the queries
might be cheap they might be that does
this Edge exist you know what the
neighbors of this vertex are some might
be expensive like I don't know find the
traveling salesman solution to this
graph
but the point is that I each of these
algorithms have to see a static view of
the graph right they can't see the graph
as it's changing and these queries are
sort of interleaved so I've drawn them
here uh you know in some arbitrary ways
you know someone comes in and says oh I
want to do a uh I know mint spanning
tree here I just want to look at the
neighbors of some vertex
right and I want to do all sorts of
things with them and that and I want to
answer them quickly and not only so I
can't basically wait until some other
query finishes okay and then I also have
a rapid set of updates and again they
can't wait uh until uh you know some
them query could take let's say I'm
doing the tsp it could take three days
okay I'm not going to hold off on my
updates until that TSB is finished I
don't need that but by the time the tsp
is finished there's going to be another
query so there's never a free time
of of not doing work so this is the old
days back in databases where it's shut
down the database from midnight till
three in the morning and they'd run the
updates okay that's not the world we're
in we want to actually have it running
continuously
so the question is how do you do this
and should be clear to you the the
problem here is the consistency is I
can't this algorithm that's running here
can't deal with a graph that's changing
over time okay this is you know we don't
want to make the user Make the
algorithms robust against changing
updates it would be a nightmare to have
to do that so each of those queries has
to see a static view of the graph
okay so that's the issue that I want to
understand
so the question is how to do this and
the cool thing is it's you know before I
showed you back data structure ideas
back from the
1982 I've moved a few years in advance
and now into 86. okay we're going to use
what are called persistent data
structures
how many of you remember these or
I can see it's the older crowd
[Laughter]
so anyone that was educated in the 80s
and maybe 90s knows about the Cincinnati
structures they're actually a really
cool idea they originally appeared in a
paper by disc golf sound oxide and Tajin
here we got slated touch and showing up
again
um and it's this idea that you basically
you keep a history of uh the uh values
of a location so normally when you write
to a location the old value disappears
okay and what we do is instead we keep a
history so if we write B and we change
it from D to F we basically we change it
from D to F but we keep sort of a linked
list of what the value looked like over
time
okay
and it turns out that this is was
actually very useful and and
sonoc intelligent the same you year
showed how you could actually use this
in a lot of uh cool uh sort of
computational geometry data structures
one of which was in in point location so
Point location is you're given a bunch
of
given a bunch of lines and you're given
a point and you want to find the line
below it or you know actually you can
turn to break this into trapezoids and
then find the trapezoid Zen it's
equivalent but let's let's just think of
the variant where for every point the
query is tell me the line below it okay
and the uh you know and we're giving us
a set of lines
and he showed the uh Sonic Sergeant
showed For the First Time how to do this
using these persistent data structures
uh using n log n's construction time
login for query and linear space
okay and it used the idea of persistent
data structures and the idea is uh
there's this class of algorithms you
might have heard of of sweep line
algorithms you basically sweep from left
to right whenever you get to a left end
point you insert it into a tree you so
you maintain a tree sorted by the y
coordinate you sweep along the x
coordinate this is an insert and all the
green lines here at the beginning the
insertions all the red lines are
deletions okay
and then what you do is if you keep a
history of what this tree looked like
across all these operations then a query
is just you go to the right tree here
and then just look it up and that's it
so once you've got the persistent data
structure this becomes easy
so well what does this have to do with
uh you know a problem at hand before I
do that let's look at something a little
bit more interesting which is a rotation
okay so this is just a standard rotation
I'm switching D and F is coming f is
coming down D is going up
and this is it's going to make three
changes to the tree because it's
basically B is now going to point to D
and D and F are both going to change
their children
okay and so this is what the persistent
data structure would look like for that
I did by the way does everyone
understand how we're maintaining
linked list okay so we're
um now
let's get back to uh you know streams
queries and updates
so our goals here one is to linearize uh
you know up basically the sequence and
so linearize is a technical term in the
concurrency Community which basically it
has to look like it happened in a
sequential order
okay and in the particular sequential
order we're going to go if we go back to
uh
position here the sequential order it's
going to appear to happen in is
everyone's going to appear to have all
the queries the updates happen in the
order they happen Okay and all the
queries are going to linearize at their
start
and maybe you're already figuring out
how we're going to use persistence here
which is we're going to somehow uh use
the we're going to basically look at the
version of the data structure which was
valid at that point of time and that the
graph and the algorithm is always going
to look at that version and time so
that's the basic idea
we want a few other uh things we want
the constant overhead for updates so
when we're making these uh updates you
know we're doing a rotation that should
take constant time okay uh this is
actually without contention so I'm
assuming that say no one else is making
an update on that same node at the same
time we want it to be constant if there
is uh these are going to be what's
called lock free in the sense that what
one person will win and the next person
will have to wait
okay so one person will get it done in
constant time anyone that's contending
might take a bit longer okay queries are
weight free again this is a technical
term which means uh even if a process
has any other process that stops they're
going to continue and succeed and this
precludes the use of locks in fact even
lock freedness up here we cannot use
locks if we want to support these so we
have to do it without locks
um and another thing we'd like to avoid
it turns out something that's
inefficient about persistent data
structures is every time you read a
pointer you go indirectly through one of
these links even if you're looking the
most recent version
uh and so uh
so anyway so uh we would like to avoid
this and have somehow be directly get a
d and that's that's purely a practical
reason not a theoretical reason
okay and so the main ideas here is uh
we're basically it's going to use the
persistent data structures you know how
do we make them safe from concurrency
and there's two two main ideas here one
is uh uh what we're going to do is use
uh copying and timestamp helping and I'm
only gonna have time to very briefly
talk about the uh the idea of partial
copying here
and the issue is getting back to here is
in the case the rotation we had to make
three changes and we want to make it
look Atomic remember we have to make it
look like these updates are happening
one at a time
okay atomically we can't in other words
we couldn't first you know change you
know B's value then F's value and then
D's value because someone that came in
would then see an inconsistent View
okay
um so again that's in this context they
all have to see a consistent view of the
graph
so the idea is uh actually very simple
although there's details which I'm going
to
wave over uh is he basically
copy dnf here so instead of mutating dnf
you create a copy of this and in general
if you're doing a larger change let's
say a change that involved you know four
or five nodes like a double rotation
then you'd have to copy everything
that's changing except for the one thing
that's sort of at the root of the change
okay at this point now when I'm doing an
update here I can just update the uh
single B is the only thing that changes
okay there's still points now I have two
versions of D I've got D and D Prime so
these are my two new vertices but I made
a single update
data sure
the next optimization is once you do
this copying uh it turns out you no
longer need the level wind direction
it's this is not true in general I'll
give you an example if you didn't do the
copying okay
you can actually have B Point directly
to D Prime
which points to F so what we're doing
now is we're sort of adding to each node
The Meta information that we need to
maintain this list which is basically a
next pointer and a time stamp
right because what we have to do at each
of these you know it should be clear
that each of these nodes we basically
keep a time stamp so that when a query
comes in it says you know after time
seven it looked like this before time
seven it looked like this right and so
each of these nodes in the linked list
has basically a next point of value and
a time stamp
and so we can just merge those into the
in this case the tree nodes okay so this
red arrow here is basically a time stamp
and a uh the next pointer
and the reason it's not obvious that
this is
correct and it wouldn't be correct if we
didn't do the copying is that now what
we have is two nodes which both point to
e here and they only have one version
list well before F Prime had a version
list and d d had a version this and
they're very different over time
so it looks like well we can't share
this version list here
okay but because of the copying this is
actually safe because this path we will
never Traverse this path okay at a time
earlier than the earliest thing in this
version list so even though this is
sharing the version list if you come
down this path you will never Traverse
that version list
and so therefore it's safe to do the uh
to have them both Point here even though
this is the incorrect version list for f
Prime
in fact F Prime just was exist just
created at this time there's no way that
the prior version list of this is
correct for f Prime
so that's the basic idea
I've only showed a
sub set of the steps but you can there's
a few more steps to make this work in a
way that's safe for concurrency the
setting it turns out the most tricky
Parts actually setting the time stamps
properly okay and
um
um so there's some tricks to do that but
once you do all this then you get the uh
the goals that we wanted which was a
concurrent updates
uh save concurrent updates and uh
you know in constant time constant time
updates and weight free queries
in fact the time for query
is if you think about it right is you
have to if you querying something at the
most recent time it's going to be the
same as it was in the original data
structure
right log in if you're going back in
time it's going to be the number of
edges you Traverse you know per look up
here and you can show that the copying
actually helps this right because when
you copy you're sort of breaking up long
chains
okay so it has the the added advantages
okay I'm going to skip a couple things
because
shut up is that correct though okay
um so
there's a sort of some open problems in
fact there's many open problems these
are just the three that came to mind
this morning
um
so in this the streaming update model uh
the
the operations we're doing on the graph
are actually standard static algorithms
right we're running like Min spanning
Tree on the graph and we're more
concerned about how to maintain them
properly as we're doing updates and so
they see a consistent view you could
imagine a combination and in the in the
uh batch Dynamic we're doing a batch of
insertions a batch of queries a batch of
you know deletions a batch of queries
what if you wanted to do batch Dynamic
algorithms but allow the queries to
happen in the middle so now I'm doing a
batch insertion like in the in the case
of the Min spanning tree and in the
middle that batch Insertion I want to do
a bunch of queries I want to figure out
what the Min spanning tree was or maybe
other queries on the graph
so there's many questions here
for those of you who are well familiar
with the slay detergent
Etc
persistent data structures that you
might Rec noticed I missed over a fine
point which is this idea of node
splitting which guarantees worst case
balance uh exactly how to do this in the
current setting is still open and this
is something that maybe I put it down
this morning but after Helen's talk you
know some of this has been
uh looked at already is how do you make
these data structures more efficient for
caches and I O
okay so that's all I have some
conclusions
basically that you know batched
algorithms not only help by allowing
parallelism they can actually reduce the
work like in the case of the
batch you know links and cuts
and can be used to leave updates and
queries
uh and that this concurrent setting can
be basically used to do so you're going
to get snapshots or consistent snapshots
so the query is going to operate while
updates are happening
okay
[Applause]
all right
okay well if you have any uh talk to God
after this uh so we have a reception now
uh from four to five pm and then
tomorrow will be
for the uh probably attractive and the 9
30.